so what if i told you you could
immediately qualify for the semi-finals
of a major tournament
and all you had to do was throw a single
match no bribes
no money exchanging hands none of that
but
because of the way the tournament is
structured you'd have to choose to lose
on purpose
now in order to potentially win big down
the line
that's a hell of a decision to make
right well
that's exactly the decision a rainbow
six siege pro league team
recently had to make and the results
have completely divided the siege scene
[Music]
alright guys subscribing to the channel
and sending a tip to our tips email
not only helps us understand what you
want to see more of but it helps us
track down those
stories and if you leave a comment on
this video about how i use my hands too
much
well i don't know what to tell you sorry
so the team that i'm talking about is
cyclops a japanese team competing out of
the asia pacific or
apac region for siege esports and back
on october 22nd
cyclops's head coach xq basically
admitted to throwing a match on twitter
and to be clear this isn't
some no-name team pogging it out in fpl
no this is a team competing at the
highest level of siege esports
i feel like the the ferocity factor from
cyclops is just scaring guts into
submission
now was admitting to throwing a match on
twitter a dumb thing to do
yeah of course like think about that
even being
accused of throwing a match is enough to
destroy somebody's career
and this guy admitted to it on social
media
on top of that cyclops blatantly
violated the rules of siege esports by
throwing that match
but before you go and completely write
this guy in cyclops
off they threw the match for what they
felt like
was a really good reason see cyclops
were competing in pro league in the
hopes of landing a high seed placement
for the upcoming apac major that's
taking place in november
now this is where this story gets kind
of complicated so
just stick with me in the apac region of
siege
teams earn points based on where they
land in the final rankings of each stage
or phase of pro league and with the end
of stage two of pro league in sight
cyclops had a dilemma on their hands if
they beat q
khan an immediate shot at the
semi-finals of that upcoming major
would still come down to who won between
cloud9
versus giants to make it even more
confusing if cloud9 beat
giants that would knock cyclops down to
fifth place
and out of the major entirely basically
if cyclops win
if they do what they're supposed to do
it still leaves their future
in a potential major appearance in the
hands of someone else
but because of the convoluted and overly
complicated structure of the point
system for aipac
pro league if cyclops lost against qcon
it would guarantee them a spot in the
semi-finals for the upcoming major
so cyclops decided not to leave things
up to chance
and they threw the match pretty [ __ ]
confusing right
now i encourage everyone to go read
falling swords reddit post on this
they break down the situation in a
minute detail by detail
way i've read it half a dozen times and
honestly i'm still confused
now when this story broke it immediately
divided the siege scene
on one hand there were people who are
saying throwing a match is throwing a
match
it doesn't matter what your reasons were
it's unacceptable
and again technically speaking cyclops
violated the rulebook
technically speaking they deserve to be
punished on the other hand
you had people blaming a system that
allowed this to happen
and not the people who were forced to
make a shitty decision
basically don't hate the player hate the
game son i don't know if there's any of
us that are gonna disagree on this
uh i'm gonna just come out and say it i
don't blame cyclops at all i would have
done the same thing
yeah i don't blame them either i don't
blame them one bit the format is dumb
the format is what needs to change you
play to succeed
cyclops guaranteed themselves a better
result by losing fair play
you don't like it change the [ __ ]
format that's it and that clip we just
showed you from entero
to me raises interesting questions about
responsibility
and how we define success as a pro
player what is your responsibility
is it to win the match right in front of
you because
if that's the case what cyclops did was
wrong but
if your responsibility is to lift a
trophy to be as successful as you can be
as a team
well then did cyclops do anything wrong
and so all of a sudden you have this
murky moral dilemma right in the middle
of what's
honestly a pretty cut and dry match
throwing scandal
now this moral gray area hasn't been
confirmed as to why ubisoft hasn't said
anything yet
but yeah as of right now neither ubisoft
nor
faceit has handed punishment down to
cyclops
my guess is that because of all of this
messiness
ubisoft and co are taking longer to
deliberate on
what the hell they should do here one
thing i could see ubisoft doing is
screwing with the point system
entirely trying to re-jig it so that
something like this doesn't happen again
but tweaking a flawed system might just
produce
more problems as for xq who you'll
remember as cyclops head coach
he replied to somebody on twitter
basically saying yeah
he was done with siege although he has
yet to make a statement officially on
the matter
honestly i still don't know what to
think about this
the rational side of my brain thinks
that clearly
some sort of punishment needs to be
handed down here
if only to try to preserve the
competitive integrity of siege esports
but my gut says that if losing within
the system that you're
forced to plan is objectively better for
your team in the long run
i'd lose every single time because the
fact is
faceit and ubisoft allowed this to
happen they created a system that
forced players to lose to blame them
when they do that
is absurd to me now should you tweet
about it after the fact and potentially
ruin your entire career
no probably not i don't understand
where my hands thing comes from like did
i just pick that up as a child
i think you're just a nervous idiot am i
just a nervous idiot yeah i mean i do
have tics
maybe you're just like you maybe you
just belong in hogwarts
i belong in hogwarts like yeah i don't
even need like a one
if you had a wand in your hand you know
it would make sense colton can you put
like a wizard hat and a beard on my face
and then like
you have a beard okay fine i have a frog
here put a wizard hat
put the sorting hat on my head and then
i'll sit there like
which house am i going to get you know
you'd be a hufflepuff
it certainly would not be one of the
main ones what the [ __ ] are their
characteristics though i don't know
anything about hufflepuff
don't being weird all right i'll take it
yeah those are the stoners of [ __ ]
hogwarts all right